nutcracker
this called four realms
nutcracker in the fight i think it's
called the photo wraps i don't care
[Music]
nutcracker in the something something
something so the nutcracker something or
rather is a new nutcracker movie it
stars mackenzie foy her mom just died
left her a riddle which is pretty much a
big metal egg with no key so she follows
this string that takes her to the
magical land of
not narnia i guess and so she stumbles
through this uninspired schlock and we
just kind of nod and go along with it
until the credits end and we go okay
i hope the kids had fun i don't have
kids nor did i watch this for kids so
of everyone i was with did not have fun
100 being me what i did like about the
movie it's
mackenzie foy i think his nice bright
future ahead of her she was the little
kid in twilight sure but she's also
murph from interstellar i thought she
was good as murph she's good in here
helen mirren's like
why am i here i don't know it's all
right helen we don't know either i just
don't know who this movie's trying to
speak
to honestly it's really goofy in parts
so i'm like all right it's obviously
meant for kids
in a couple parts i'm like that's a bit
too creepy for kids so is it trying to
be kitty or is it trying to be creepy i
don't know
i guess movies are trying to weed them
out they're trying to find the kids who
are messed up enough to not be creeped
out by some of this stuff and they shall
take us into the future i feel like some
of the cast just got swallowed up by the
scope of this cartoon like the dude who
plays the nutcracker was in ready player
one and this and that's it which is fine
someone could be in only two things and
still be great and i'm sure he's
really nice in real life which is what
critics and reviewers say before they
start ripping into somebody i'm not
gonna rip into the dude i'm just saying
he doesn't stand out he gets swallowed
up in this whole thing i forgot he was
even supposed to be the nutcracker until
like the end of this movie and even just
now right before i was gonna film this i
was like
oh that's right that dude's the
nutcracker that dude's the title
character in this movie and he's barely
memorable benefit of the doubt i feel
like that's on the directors writers the
game makers not him and this movie's
nutcracker because well there is a
nutcracker character but what else is
nutcracker and has
some of the music some of the time to
remind you that hey this was supposed to
be in the nutcracker world there's
nothing particularly nutcracker-ish
about this story not from what i
remember anyway this take is so far
removed it might as well not be called
the nutcracker because it comes across
the second-rate narnia movie i know the
nutcracker pre-dates narnia just how it
comes across
keira knightley's so cartoony in this
movie seriously sometimes she's the
sugar plum fairy then there's these
soldiers and she's like oh man
in uniform it doesn't do that second
part it was still
really awkward and weird she's just
making comments and there's a scene
where these ten soldiers are being
brought to life they're gonna fight and
someone's like that won't work ten
soldiers are hollow i was like well
birds of a feather they're in here if
hollow things don't work how did this
movie get
green lit
because this movie just does it comes
across as boring hollow and lifeless
like disney's like we have a monopoly in
all of our disney properties marvel star
wars what else can we get
christmas looks like they're like well
kids like those alice in wonderland
movies we'll make another one of those
kind of which is funny because i would
rather watch those alice in wonderland
movies than this in any case if you're
going to take the kids to see a movie
don't take them to see this and if you
do take them to see this they might be
entertained for some of it they might
have nightmares because of other parts
but for my dollar there's not a thing i
liked about this movie and this movie in
fact
is dog all right so nutcracker
something about the four realms have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's the worst kids movie you've seen
lately whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you